what's going on guys this is Rob and I
have a couple questions for you guys
question number one how many of you want
to become a full time youtuber who wants
to learn what it takes to become a full
time youtuber meaning you make videos
full time on whatever it happens to be
you know vlogging or gaming or or how
many books or what-have-you
how many of you want to learn how to do
that how many of you know that I'm
engaged to be married and how many of
you know that the woman of the the name
of the woman I'm engaged to be married
to is Mariah how many of you guys know
that how many of you know that before I
became a full-time youtuber I worked as
a dispatcher for the University of
Kentucky and before that I was a fry
cook working at Long John Silver's
making fish and chicken how many of you
guys knew that did I came from virtually
nothing and became a full-time youtuber
how many think ask me that I doubt very
many of you did now if you're curious
about any of that
then I've got a link to my vlogging
channel in the description so here's the
question this is probably the million
dollar question you're asking whether
you know it or not if I tell you that I
have a vlogging channel and if I tell
you that you should check my vlogging
channel out the question you'd probably
ask is why why should I care about this
crazy man's vlogging channel when all I
care about this comics well because the
reality is about vlogging channel
addresses a litany of different things
and a lot of the things that are on
there are things that you guys have
requested a lot of you guys have asked
me to make videos on a history of World
War two which I have I'm currently seven
parts into a 12 part series on a history
of World War two those of you guys who
like my videos on a history of the
Marvel Universe it's almost exactly like
that
and after World War two I'm gonna do the
cold war which is far grander in scale
not only in terms of everything that
happened but in terms of its length so
it's it's much much bigger it'll be a
huge undertaking but that's something
that's coming later on down the line if
I you know if it depending on how that
does I may go back into World War one
I've got videos that deal with things
that you guys didn't even know about
I've got a video that runs over the life
of Rob you know although it's really the
finer points you know that I'm sorry the
the big talking points not really the
finer points but they're big points on
how I got from being young and the
earliest memories I have running all the
way up to when I became a full-time
youtuber the things that I've
experienced over the course of my life
I've got videos talking about what I
want to do you know after YouTube
because one day this will all fizzle out
there's the things that I want to do
myself and Mariah have video have a
video together like we're gonna make
more videos together others there's all
kinds of things on that channel that
directly affect you that will that will
help you get to the things you're going
through because I know you guys struggle
with anxiety I know you guys struggle
with trying to fit in I know you
struggle with trying to find your
identity I know you struggle with like
depression I know you struggle with
organizational issues with how to manage
money with how credit works I know you
guys struggle with all that stuff and
the videos on that channel or designed
to help you with that designed to help
you along the road to becoming the
person that you want to be one day and
so so for those of you guys who are
interested check it out right because I
mean I've never really advertised it
I've never leaned made a dedicated video
where I'm like here's the thing I have
you guys should all go check it out
honestly I want to be create a backlog
right now I think it's somewhere about
like 80 videos maybe somewhere around
there on a number off top my head but
it's got a backlog it's got a pretty
pretty good-sized backlog here's kind of
a funny thing
one of the most common questions that I
get whether through email or comments is
one will you give me a shout-out on my
youtube channel or two will you tell me
how to grow one well of course I'll be
making a video series on how to grow one
but in terms of giving you a shout out
one of the reasons why I don't really do
that is because when I go and look at
those YouTube channels they don't have a
backlog they've got like three videos
and maybe start other channel like a
week ago
or if they have three videos and they
started their channel like a year ago
and they've uploaded three videos over
the course of that year there's no real
frequency there like there's no reason
for anybody to want to stay like don't
watch those three videos then they'll
leave and they'll forget about their
channel and so when it occurred to me
that I never really like to sort of
reply on well hey here's what you're
doing wrong here's how to fix it or at
least here's how I think you should fix
it though the fact that I never did that
kind of made me think well I should make
a video series on how to do that on how
to become a youtuber you know like all
these little things that I've learned
over the years and and so on they're so
close I mean I've got one video called
the three rules of YouTube right like
like and I think it's called the rules
of YouTube the other one is the three
rules of life but there's the rules of
YouTube like the things you need to know
if you want to run a YouTube channel
like the bare-bones things you need to
know but I'll create a more in-depth
series of videos on how all that works
you know is interesting because when it
when it comes to like the audio and
video on those other channels I don't
really care about that but like it
doesn't really run it's not really
relevant to me because everybody for the
most part starts out at the bottom of
the barrel right like those of you guys
remember when I first started my channel
this was in 2014 or something like that
me on 2015 I had
logitech c920 webcam and like a blue
yeti I was by no means a top-tier
vlogger not by any standard of
measurement but especially when it came
to like talking on camera now even the
audio quality was lackluster now of
course that began to change they began
upgrade and I didn't really show myself
on camera all that often so having a
c920 didn't really matter but I went
from having that basic of the set up
basically what I had on hand something
that I could put together from 250 bucks
to having a a Canon c920 I'm sorry that
Canon C 200 cinema camera and an MK h
416 I could shoot a movie with this
setup right now like it's it's it's hat
like it's it's kind of where it's moved
up and progressed to and if you're
looking to do that if you're looking to
launch a YouTube channel and understand
that you start out at the very bottom
for the most part bare-bones materials
and work your way up to where you can
create almost like cinema style vlogs or
really really well produced a really
really well produced product yeah
I've run burgundy uhm the videos on my
channel will help you do that so so yeah
that's that's really one of the big
reasons why I started that channel was
to kind of get an understanding of the
life of Rob of me as a person when I'm
about but I believe how I see the world
beyond the realm of comics beyond the
scope of comics but to also tie into
things that can help you guys out
directly so that's your answer for why
you should go see it because it's
literally a channel design note to help
you improve your life in the ways that
you're looking to improve it not every
video is gonna resonate with you but I
would bet that more than a few probably
would so if you guys are interested
check the link down in the description
of course I will have the link on the on
the video down here on the the bottom of
the video so you guys can go check it
out but it's pretty simple youtube.com
slash Robert Jefferson or just search on
YouTube according to Rob and you'll find
you'll find that that channel but yeah
um it's videos just as arne to kind of
get to know me better and I hope you
guys navigate this crazy ocean that we
call life whoo that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
and that will catch you all later
[Music]